And the happiest people on Earth are officially...
the Norwegians.
They eat lots of fresh seafood.
They live with breathtaking scenery.
And the long dark winters don't seem to dampen
their spirits.
For the first time, Norway's taken the top
spot on the United Nations World Happiness
Report.
"Is Norway number one?
Wow!"
"It is not the weather because it's very cold,
but I think it's the nature and the people."
"It's a free country, you can speak your mind."
"We can appreciate changes and we are also
content with it."
Joar Vittersø is a psychologist and happiness
researcher.
He's been trying to find out what makes people
contented with their lives - or not - since
the 1980s.
And why are his own countrymen at the top
of the international ranking?
"People are more equal here than they are
in other places in the world.
And that has a lot of benefits to it, for
example people trust each other more when
they are on equal footing.
And trust, we know, is a very important factor
for you to thrive and be comfortable and satisfied
with your life."
The northern city of Tromsø can serve as
an example.
The educational system is excellent.
The state provides health care, and unemployment
and poverty are low.
Joar Vittersø works at the Arctic University
of Tromsø - the world's northernmost.
He asserts that the positive attitude of people
in the high north plays a big part in their
overall contentment.
"In some parts of the world you actually see
that the less daylight, the more depression
you can observe.
That is not the case in Norway.
In Northern Norway, it seems that people have
found ways of adapting to the dark period.
They have activities they look forward to
conduct during the winter which compensate
and even more than compensate for the dark
period."
Skiing, the national sport, was even invented
in Norway.
Tromsø has plenty of snow on the ground for
six months a year.
The northern lights and sled-dog runs are
part of life.
During the short summers, many Norwegians
love to go hiking with family and friends.
The law allows everyone to make camp and even
build a fire in the open.
"In Norwegian it's called 'allemannsretten'.
That's a very long tradition in Norway.
I think it's almost a thousand years old.
You are allowed to trespass other people's
property, you can even hunt there, but it
should be in agreement with the owner, but
the owner cannot deny you accessing it and
using it."
From the age of two, children at this day-care
center in Tromsø spend their days outside
- no matter what the weather.
Kjell Kampevoll co- founded this open-air
day-care center - one of many in Norway.
He believes the key to happiness can be found
in the Norwegians' closeness to nature.
"Yes, I really think that my kids are really
happy.
More kids play together without fighting."
Birgit Hem and Conrad Helgeland live with
their four children not far from Tromsø.
They both have jobs and share the housework.
They make an extra effort to make their home
cozy - 'koselig' in Norwegian - especially
when it's cold outside.
"I think Norwegians like having a cozy home
and candles when it's dark and make nice food
and be with their family and have a good time."
Birgit Hem is also quite happy that she doesn't
have to worry about her children's future.
Joar Vittersø says governments can do much
to enhance the people's happiness - but individuals
can, too.
"I think that we need more attention towards
what really matters in our lives.
I think actually it's good for people to reflect
a little bit upon what is important for me,
what should I do with my life and not just
go along the flow and follow what is supposed
to be the road to success."
Norwegians have their own word for a special
kind of happiness.
'Utepils' - to sit in the sunshine and enjoy
a beer.
During the Arctic summers with over 20 hours
of daylight, Norwegians have plenty of opportunity
to experience these happy moments.